wer eine promi im gefängnis janina zwei
andere vor gericht johnny depp und amber
debatte seiner extra wegen verleumdung
auf 50 millionen dollar verklagt sie
habe mit ihren gewalt anschuldigung
seinen ruf geschädigt und seine karriere
zerstört herz anwälte hatten jetzt
mitten im prozess einen antrag auf
abweisung dieser klage gestellt hat das
gericht aber zurückgewiesen und so
werden wir weitere intime details aus
dieser vergifteten beziehungen erfahren
werden amber heard heute und in den
nächsten tagen den zeugenstand betritt
das interesse daran ist weiter riesige
schlangen vor gericht im us bundesstaat
virginia
was ist da zu erwarten wenn er jetzt
auftritt ja also zunächst aber will ich
sagen ich finde das völlig irre diese
bilder die wir da sehen von den fans und
johnny depp die nacht davor kempen und
darauf warten also seine fangemeinde ist
wirklich richtig stark aber was wir
erwarten von der aussage von ember
schmutz sehr viel schmutz denn sie muss
alles tun um ihn irgendwie zu
degradieren um klar zu machen dass er
ein gewalttäter ist und gestern hat
schon ihre psychologin ausgesagt eine
psychologin die sie untersucht hat
während der ehe mit johnny depp die ihr
eine posttraumatische belastungsstörung
diagnostiziert hat während der
angeblichen gewalt in der ehe mit johnny
depp und sie hat eine situation
geschildert die wird die einem wirklich
unter die haut gehen und zwar sollen
johnny depp und amber hört in einer
wohnwagensiedlung gewesen sein er war
wahnsinnig eifersüchtig weil sie
angeblich von einer frau an geflirtet
wurde und hat sich dann auf die suche
nach drogen gemacht weil er war
angeblich so ein bisschen paranoia und
hatte auch immer angst dass sie zuviel
flirte dass sie sich zu sehr auf donnert
und dass sie drogen nimmt und ich habe
diese szene diesen ausschnitt denen die
psychologin dr hughes im gericht
ausgesagt hat einmal mitgebracht die
können wir uns einmal zusammen anschauen
weil die ist wirklich heftig
er führte eine leibesvisitation durch
und suchte ausgiebig nach drogen er
hielt es für akzeptabel dass nach dem
vom leibe zu reisen und seine finger in
ihre vagina zu stecken um dort nach
kokain zu suchen er dachte dass sie es
vielleicht dort versteckt hatte dort bei
bischofsheim
ja es wird johnny depp hat die vagina
von amber heard durchsucht und
möglicherweise dort kokain zu finden und
wenn wir diese aussagen hören dann
wissen wir ja fast genau eine aussage
eine anschuldigung aber wenn wir das
hören das ist die zeugen von amber heard
denn wissen wir was da auf uns zukommen
kann wenn er hört aussagt und wir haben
ja bilder aus dem gerichtssaal denn die
verhandlung läuft gerade amber heard ist
heute das erste mal erschien ohne
make-up hier sehen wir johnny depp
grauer anzug krawatte sonnenbrille wie
immer wir wissen ja hat eine
augenkrankheit deswegen kann er nicht so
gut gucken deswegen trägt er immer eine
brille die haare wieder zum zopf
gebunden und amber heard was wirklich
heute aufgefallen ist da sehen wir noch
mal im gericht sie heute das erste mal
ohne make up das ist jetzt das livebild
höre ich gerade also man sitzt schon
wieder im gericht dort geht es jetzt
gleich weiter
es könnte sein dass die psychologen noch
weiter aus sagt ansonsten ist dann amber
heard dran mit ihrer aussage die wie ich
eben gerade sagte heute das erste mal
ohne make-up
gericht sitzt das ist micro management
mikromanagement na das ist natürlich
alles gestellt hier sehen wir die
psychologin die bereits auch gestern
ausgesagt hat die heute dann auch noch
mal von der gegenseite ins kreuzverhör
genommen wird und alle warten im prinzip
darauf dass amber heard dann gleich aus
sagt und in den zeugenstand tritt und
die experten erwarten wirklich deftiges
es wird auf jeden fall spannend wir
haben ja in der vergangenen woche schon
live übertragen stunden lang als johnny
depp ausgesagt hatte und das war ja
faszinierend man hängt das schon an den
lippen es ist wie ein krimi wer aber
real stattfindet
hollywood hätte das drehbuch nicht
besser schreiben können und wir beide
haben gemeinsam geguckt dass der gerade
schon gesagt das ist faszinierend und
schockierend zugleich
etwas anwälte haben gestern noch hier
sieht man sie heute ich glaube es sind
ältere fotos
amber heard anwälte haben gestern noch
versucht den prozess abzublasen die
haben gestern noch versucht den
abzubrechen und haben gesagt johnny depp
hat nicht genug beweise wir wollen dass
dieses verfahren eingestellt wird aber
die richterin buck knallhart und hat
gesagt nein es geht weiter amber muss in
den zeugenstand wir sind gespannt darauf
was wir da zu hören bekommen werden
natürlich darüber berichten giannina
kirsch vielen dank für den moment